mit diesem Trick landet nie wieder
Schale in euren Eiern das einzige was
wir brauchen sind Eier und eine Schüssel
wir werden das Ei jetzt nicht am
Schüsselrand aufschlagen nicht auf einer
flachen Oberfläche nein brauchen einfach
nur ein weiteres Ei weil immer wenn man
zwei Eier zusammen Haut geht nur eins
perfekt kaputt jedes Mal ganz kaputt und
ihr seht vielleicht hier ist so ein
perfekter Crack der Länge nach
entstanden und ich kann das Ei einfach
in die Schüssel geben ich habe das jetzt
seit Wochen nicht anders gemacht es ist
wirklich nie schade dabei ich weiß auch
nicht warum aber es ist einfach Magie
nächster Beweis könnte sogar ein
bisschen rumschlagen Zack und
perfekt jedes Mal wenn es nicht glauben
könnt probiert selbst aus